it's official chris and catherine pratt
are celebrating their new bundle of joy
the proud parents announced the birth of
their daughter with this sweet photo
holding her hand her name lila maria
schwarzenegger pratt the middle name
maria is of course a tribute to
catherine's mother
congratulations on becoming an uncle
thank you first time uncle patrick first
broke the baby news sunday
in this exclusive video obtained by e.t
how is uh
catherine and the baby doing doing great
just got her a little gift
let's do it chris who was recently in
london shooting jurassic world dominion
was there for the birth and quote the
couple can't take their eyes off their
daughter
i'm in it baby i'm in it but it's good
it feels good good things happening for
me
in life i count my blessings every day
chris's car was seen friday around 2 p.m
outside st john's hospital in santa
monica
by 5 pm the family brigade started
arriving to the couple's nearby home
that's grandpa arnold smoking a cigar ex
maria drove separately with her kids
christina and christopher
our source says catherine is doing well
and quote enjoying the experience of
being a first-time mother
pratt of course has seven-year-old son
jack with ex-wife anna faris
oh man i'm lucky god is good i feel
really good really blessed
e.t has learned jurassic world dominion
still has a couple months left of
production
if chris returns to the uk set it would
kind of be a pattern for him
i'm in england right now and my wife and
my child are back in l.a
back in 2013 he also had to leave then
wife anna
and their son jack to film guardians of
the galaxy
the hardest thing about this role has
been being away from my family our
source says
catherine is so grateful to have chris
by her side for now
quote everything is new for catherine
and she's glad chris is there to help
her through everything